hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel today I'm doing another
Q&A feeding 80,000 subscribers thank you
all so much for subscribing it's kind of
insane eighty thousand is a lot of
people but seriously thank you all so
much for all your support I really
appreciate it and let's get to the
questions
Austin s tell us you're willing to go on
a blind date with a guy who has great
morals Congrats on your morals but no I
would actually never go on a blind date
I don't care if I'm single or if I'm in
a relationship both of those states are
fine to me so if I am single I don't
actively seek a relationship I would
never go on dating websites I'd never go
on a blind date I'm just kind of content
with being single so basically the only
way I can get in a relationship is if
somebody that I happen to like stumbles
in my life somehow and it just happens
from there I never actually push you it
the air you pee Terry Gary I'm sorry and
I have to say name-o
why do you want to be in ten years in
relation to your career do you have any
specific goals or do you take it as it
comes I am a very driven and goal
orientated person I if I don't have a
goal I step one and then I hit it and
then I make the next one and that's how
I live life is by trying really hard to
accomplish things so after getting the
job at IGN which is something that has
been like my golf the past three and a
bit years technically four years since I
started writing back games I have no
idea what I want to do now it's kind of
crippling Reese read us what upcoming
gaming title are you most excited about
in 2016 and congressional issues by the
way obviously thank you
this year I'm mostly excited about
ukulele I feel like it's probably not
going to come out this year I think it's
gonna get delayed but being optimistic
I'm still gonna give that as my answer
there's a lot about this stuff that I'm
really interested in like the division
I'm really interested in horizon zero
dawn I think what's really cool and of
course one PlayStation VR stuff I'm also
excited about new uncharted and new
Gears of War Geoffroy so to say no
that's cool I like that good username oh
I'll give you a collection of figurines
and toys what is your most cherished so
it's tough I think my favorite statue
back in Australia which I didn't really
bring many of them with me as a couple
you can see up here but these are all
things that I fought since I've been in
the u.s. um the one in Australia would
be two Renea
I bought it for myself for my 21st
birthday it was very very expensive it's
a
biggest statue I've already bought two
new ones this year that are currently on
pre-order which is a matter of Sue and a
Zelda
first of all just make amazing statues
but the dirtiest specifically is because
you know it was 20 plus but they brought
it to myself and it was kind of when I
hit the point where I was actually
making enough money off of writing about
video games to me to be able to afford
that so it just felt like a really
significant thing like if I hadn't
played ocarina of time as a kid I never
would have gone through all of the
things in life that led me to this point
that symbolizes that whole journey but
it's also good that he's a great
character and it's a beautiful Statute
feel like I probably spoke about a lot
more of my favorites in the video that I
did that was at the start of last year
if you want to go back and find that
Russian pruitt us do you like majora's
mask or ocarina of time better by the
way congrats again thank you on paper
Majora's Mask is my favorite Zelda game
by a mile
I feel like mechanically and just the
way that it deals with one of the themes
it's really well done and kind of
unparalleled in some ways it's it's dark
and it's creepy and I love the three day
cycle and the repetition I think that's
amazing but I actually don't have that
much fun when I'm playing it so there's
this weird thing when I'm thinking about
Majora's Mask I get really enthused and
passionate when I'm playing Majora's
Mask
I don't exactly feel that same way my
favourite Zelda game is probably Wind
Waker and in terms of actually playing
it I think I prefer playing ocarina of
time - Majora's Mask
but I still appreciate Majora's Mask
more as a game if that makes sense
Burak hello asks what is the best
experience working for a GN so far it's
really hard to pinpoint one thing that
I've enjoyed it ign's so just as a
blanket I'm gonna say I love the people
I work with every time that I want
podcasts beyond to have a lot of fun
because that's like a room full of
people I really like and we talk like
that when we're not on that podcast so
that's really comfortable Marcus
amenties semantics is my go-to character
in Soul Calibur by the way Aust did you
ever see Mad Max fury road and did you
enjoy it yes I did see fury road and it
was easily my favorite movie of last
year only
but I think X X mark and I came out last
year as well then that would be my
favorite movie of last year
fury road would come right after I
before it's Birdman I bought Mad Max is
just absolutely amazing in wild as he
asked your face time their dog was um no
I used to try and FaceTime with my dog
and sometimes I still do but FaceTime
with my family is really cool because I
can talk to them they were react to
things I say they laugh at my dumb jokes
I'll off with this it's you know you're
interacting one of my FaceTime with my
dog it's actually just me staring at her
and true my desperately wishing that I
could interact with her and not being
able to so facetiming with my animals
actually just makes me sad so I don't
really actively seek it out Carlos asked
both Mary kill kratos gerelds caribbean
and nathan drake i would i would kill
kratos gone a wall he's kind of a dick
he's pretty wengie not a fan I would
marry Nathan Drake and I would F would
Geralt Nathan wild ass what was the
hardest part about studying YouTube and
sticking with it to where you are now so
that's not the way that I approached you
to but all I started my youtube as like
a extra portfolio and basically as a way
to get better presenting people
sometimes say Karen that to represent a
and that's complete crap I was a
terrible presenter when I started I
think most people are so I started on
YouTube to get better at that and also
to learn to edit it was something that I
wanted to learn to do to add to my
portfolio as a writer to basically make
me more employable in games media so I
never approached YouTube in a way I'm
like I'm gonna be successful on YouTube
and I wouldn't consider this channel to
be successful I have a really very
community on here but it's not a big
channel so the question that you're
asking um doesn't really apply to me
you treat something that I did for fun
it's not something that I like stuck
with to try and get eighty thousand
subscribers or anything a whole lot of
people also ask me a lot of questions
about what it's like living in America
but I already uploaded a video about
that last year sometime which is like
America buses Australian impression sore
I would say check that one out and again
a lot of people are stuff that I've
answered in all the Q&A so if your
question didn't get answered here it's
because either my answer isn't very
interesting or I've already answered it
in another Q&A like what's my favorite
game how did I stop gaming
why didn't I start writing about games
or all stuff that I covered in with my
first few Q&A is and that is it for me
today everyone thank you to everyone who
some questions and don't thank you to
everyone who congratulated me all of it
worth of support I really appreciate it
thank you guys for watching I will see
you next time bye